Ще кілька тижнів тому - жвава торгівля квітами напередодні жіночого дня.
А тепер квіткова крамниця на межі банкрутства.
За два тижні національного карантину десятки кілограмів квітів довелося утилізувати.
Бізнес довелося перевести в онлайн.
Дрібний бізнес зазнає шалених збитків.
Дехто зачинився.
А дехто попри протиепідеміологічні правила -
досі торгує.
- Що буде,як думаєте?
- Будемо помирати - значить, будемо помирати.
Таких відкритих кіосків чикав’ярень на колесах
у Києві залишається дедалі менше.
За таку торгівлю почаливиписувати величезні штрафи.
Власники цих кіосків у відчаї.
Адже карантин карантином,
а їм треба повертати гроші за товар, платити оренду
і врешті-решт годувати свої сім'ї.
- Будете працювати далі?
- Доводиться працювати.
Питання сплати оренди - наразі найболючіше
для багатьох дрібних та середніх компаній.
Далеко не всі орендодавці
виконують рекомендації влади -
відтермінувати або зменшити оплату
на період карантину.
Підприємці кажуть: диктувати свої умови орендодавцям
і не платити оренду за закриті магазини, не можуть.
У нас є, звичайно, низка проблем з торговими центрами.
Одна наша агенція якраз розташована в ТРЦ і наразі все йде до суду.
Вони не хочуть йти нам назустріч задля зменшення орендної плати,
яка в торговому центрі дуже висока.
Всі інші орендодавці, де ми маємо офіси з продажу турів,
пішли нам на поступки і надали нам знижки майже50 відсотків.
Дар’я Артеменко не знає, як довго ще
протримається на плаву її туристична компанія.
Фірма витратила величезні кошти на термінове повернення
українських туристів з-за кордону,
які застрягли там через коронавірус.
Наразі Дар'я намагаєтьсядомовитися
з кількома сотнями клієнтів,
аби вони не вимагали повернення грошей за травневі та літні тури,
а просто перенесли їх на більш пізній період.
Власниця турфірми хоче, щоб Верховна Рада якнайшвидше ухвалила
обіцяний антикризовий законопроект, який би, серед іншого,
врегулював питання відносин з орендодавцями під час карантину.
Бо від інших, уже ухвалених захоодів для підтримки бізнесу,
як-от відтермінування сплати податку за землю та нерухомість
або скасування єдиного соціального внеску,
турфірма Дар'ї жодного полегшення не відчує.
Ми як товариство з обмеженою відповідальністю.
У нас немає ніяких податкових знижок.
Ми би хотіли, аби нам зробили податкові канікули
на період карантину.
І позбавили хоча б на рік перевірок.
Український виробник дверей у Дніпрі - "Міністерство дверей" -
40 відсотків продукції
зазвичай відправляв на експорт.
Тепер іноземні замовники через карантин у своїх країнах відмовляються від товару.
Керівництво компанії поки підтримує бізнес за рахунок власних коштів
коштів і розраховує на замовлення на внутрішньому ринку України,
адже багато будівельних компаній поки не припинили роботи.
У компанії розуміють, що держава не зможе допомогти всім підприємцям,
але сподіваються бодай на якісь ефективні заходи
підтримки національного виробника.
Ми багато співпрацюємо з Китаєм:
купуємо запчастини, комплектуючі тощо.
Гадаю, треба взяти за приклад, як вони нині
максимально підтримують своїх підприємців:
і курсом долар-юань, і швидким поверненням ПДВ,
і податки їм скасували тимчасово.
Україна не зможе довго стримувати падіння гривні,
вважають опитаніDWпідприємці.
Немає ресурсів і для повноцінних податкових канікул,
як це обіцяють у низці країн ЄС.
Профільні асоціації підприємців прогнозують хвилю банкрутств.
Тільки в турбізнесі, за підрахунками Асоціації туризму,
можуть збанкрутувати до сімдесяти відсотків компаній.
Це потягне за собою ще одну серйозну проблему- безробіття.
За оцінками, це щонайменше півмільйона людей вже цього року.
Працівники цих кіосків у підземних переходах
ховають свої товари від відеокамер і від нацгвардійців.
Не на камеру зізнаються, що поки
ці ковбаси та сири купують -
доти в них є заробіток.
- У Вас буде робота?
-  Мабуть, не буде. Буду сидіти вдома.
За підрахунками екс-міністра економіки Тимофія Милованова,
за березень більшість працевлаштованих українців
через простій в економіці недоотримають у середньому по5000гривень.
УСпілці українських підприємців вважають,що уряду слід уже тепер
знизити ставки податків до фонду оплати праці,
щоб запобігти масовим звільненням.
Податки - це найбільше навантаження для тих компаній,
які офіційно працевлаштовують людей і сплачують податки в повній мірі.
Це наша найбільша стаття видатків.
Тут потрібна перша допомога.
Якщо люди не працюють, то ти не можеш їм сплачувати, немає надходжень,
ти не можеш їм платити зарплату, якщо навіть хочеш.
Ти можеш їх відправити у відпустку за свій рахунок,
але це не можебути вічно, або звільняти.
Іншого виходу немає.
Зараз, можливо, треба зробити
податкові канікули для всіх.
У Спілці українських підприємців також вважають за необхідне
переформатувати нещодавно запроваджену державну програму
з дешевих кредитів для підприємців у 5-7-9 відсотків.
Приміром, задля пільгових програм поповнення зарплатних фондів.
Кілька бізнес-асоціацій також скерували до Верховної Ради
пропозиції щодо збільшення кредитних лімітів для підприємців,
заборони збільшення банками відсоткової ставки,
скасування пенІ за несвоєчасну оплату.
На думку експертки в галузі туризму Юлії Алексєєвої,
Верховна Рада та уряд мають розробити
чітку економічну стратегію виходу з кризи.
Розробити нарешті економічну стратегію України,
в якій буде чітко вказано: які в нас галузі будуть пріоритетні,
які показники ми хочемо досягти, яким інструментарієм це має робитися.
І це має бути не якась калька з інших держав,
ні якась радянська історія,
а насправді така інноваційна проривна стратегія.
Яку в нас є фахівці, які можуть це зробити.
Це має бути "план Маршалла
для України на сьогодні".
ТаксистиКиєва теж уже думають про пошуки іншого підзаробітку.
Кажуть, що з моменту запровадження карантину
вони більше стоять, ніж перевозять пасажирів.
Можливо, десь у службу доставки потрібно.
Люди наразі додому замовляють багато.
Можливо, там є робота.Їсти-то хочеться…
Можливості з пошуку роботи на час карантину обмежені.
Усі офіси перейшли на дистанційний режим.
У турфірмі "Забугор" не хочуть втрачати свій персонал -
тут працевлаштовані 12 людей.
Але зарплати, каже власниця, доведеться зменшити.
Кілька бізнес-асоціацій закликали владу терміново ухвалити
антикризові закони і виконати умови МВФ
для надання чергового кредиту в розмірі 8 мільярдів доларів.
Але тут м'яч знову на полі народних депутатів.
Умова МВФ - якщо Верховна Рада проголосує в другому читанні за земельну реформу
і за закон про неможливість повернення
націоналізованих банків колишнім акціонерам.